es beginnt wie ein disney
nach dem tode seiner alkoholkranken
mutter wird der neunjährige ek spitzname
zum kini weise
der polizist dämmung bringt ihn ins
kinderheim
liebevoll gestaltete plastilin figuren
und computer generiert kulissen zeichnen
den animationsfilm aus
regisseur blutbad der aufwand hat sich
gelohnt
was 90.000 zuschauer sahen den film la
vie de korsett allein in der westschweiz
im heim muss korsett sich völlig neu
zurechtfinden
seine neuen mitbewohner machen ihm das
leben auch nicht gerade leicht
nur der polizist räumung wird zu einem
vertrauten und dann kommt eines tages
ins kinderheim und plötzlich erwacht
ganz unerwartet die erste liebe von der
idee bis zum fertigen film vergingen
zehn jahre bis zucchini die leinwand
erobert
[Musik]
täglich wurde an mehreren sets
gleichzeitig gedreht
pro drehort ergab dass pro tag maximal
drei sekunden film video korsett gilt
bereits jetzt als größte erfolg in der
geschichte des schweizer animationsfilms
viel wichtiger aber der film berührt
kinder wie erwachsene herzen